[Musique]
il ya une situation
en guadeloupe qui est absolument
intolérable et inacceptable ils sont
plusieurs centaines chaque nuit à
dresser des barrages à brûler des
voitures
le visage masqué comme des ombres cette
petite minorité qui bloqué par les mots
par les paroles les personnes qui
voulaient se faire vacciner aujourd'hui
elle s'est radicalisée et elle essaye de
les bloquer les intimider par la
violence emmanuel macron je ne comprends
déjà pas n'a pas compris les gilets
jaunes qui manifestaient en métropole il
n'a pas compris cette france là donc il
est difficile d'aller comprendre une
france qui vit à dix mille kilomètres et
qui a des problèmes de fond que les
responsables politiques ont sciemment
oublié ont sciemment méprisé ont
sciemment a abandonné sur ce giratoire
cet automobiliste rennes une carcasse de
voiture si les encouragements
au petit matin les habitants découvrent
des scènes de chaos
sur des points de blocage certains
habitants sont pris à partie par des
antilles mesures sanitaires de 1250
policiers et gendarmes que nous avons
décidé depuis 48 heures et jusqu'à
maintenant qui arrivent dans les
prochaines heures pour une grande partie
des forces supplémentaires que nous lui
avons octroyé des avions sont partis
pour pouvoir rétablir l'ordre et
notamment une cinquantaine d'agents du
gipn et du raid
ce n'est certainement pas le gign et le
raid que j'enverrai là bas c'est une
égérie d'un barrage à gérer d'abord pour
écouter la profondeur de sa vie qu elle
n est pas ramener le calme à bord non il
faut d'abord écouter pour que l'on
envoie 250 militaires et policiers c'est
que justement on prend au sérieux cette
situation et qu'on ne veut pas la
laisser s'installer à la fois sur le
plan sécuritaire mais aussi plus
globalement comme je vous le disais
comme jean castex va recevoir les élus
de guadeloupe il y à des décisions qui
seront prises nous sommes dans un monde
extrêmement peu tranquille avec le
développement des violences et des
risques le développement des menaces sur
lesquels il nous faut être très très
vigilant oui le monde dans lequel nous
vivons après le col vide est un monde
plus grave que celui qu'on connaissait
avant pays bas on te hau ssier connu une
nouvelle nuit d'affrontements entre les
opposants aux restrictions sanitaires et
la police cette fois après rotterdam à
c'est la vie que les manifestants ont
occupé je suis d'accord avec vous
surtout d'oublier ça commence bien la
chasse
la chasse le week-end moi je suis
d'accord pour qu'on interdise le
nucléaire je suis pas spécialement pour
j'aime bien les éoliennes l'élection est
encore dans cinq mois je vous le redis
très sereinement très tranquillement je
suis convaincu que je serai au second
tour de cette élection et je vous le dis
aussi sereinement et tranquillement je
suis convaincu que je gagnerais cette
élection présidentielle mais voilà ce
jalozai les faire les meetings avec moi
même c'est qu'on fait qu et % coton fait
vu % on est au mois de novembre en
déplacement à la recherche de
financement auprès des expatriés
français demain ils m'ont dit de ne pas
faire comme nicolas sarkozy je leur ai
promis c'est à dire
vous savez moi si je dis que je passe le
karcher je le passerai la différence moi
je suis convaincu et la gagne et qu'on
va gagner à laure manaudou
20 que vous allez être présent leur
public je suis convaincu qu'on va gagner
cette élection présidentielle et qu'on
gagnera les élections déjà libre donc
entendez moore venir expliquer que
pétain et de gaulle c'est la même chose
se [ __ ] du monde au point de dire je
suis un erp erp mais monsieur zemmour si
monsieur pasqua était là il filera une
balle dans la tête ses premiers pas
politiques
mon voisin qui n'est pas équipé on voit
qu'il n'est pas fait pour cela qu'ils
enchaînent politique polémique et qui
passe son temps à taper contre tout le
monde c'est un semeur de haine un summer
de fragmentation de la société française
un summer de division et à matador du
déclinisme si simplement que la passe
quoi bon camarade tu en aurais pris une
belle épine tu l'aurais mérité voilà